hello and welcome to mark appliers new
new home tour because I am incredibly
original we're starting in the bathroom
so spaces for group activities
look it's my shrine to Santa Christmas
is right around the corner bang the poop
gods may their blessings never rain upon
my hand look at the shower look at the
amenities allow me to whoopsies
Wow we'll just ignore that because I'm
a-okay
isn't that right me now on to the
walk-in closet
filled with my battle armor and battle
squid ready for any apocalypse to happen
ah that is fresh always remember to
pelvic thrust your way out of bathrooms
for everyone's safety now on to the
master bedroom look at that man
everybody dance if you're feeling fresh
today hmm that's enough of that look at
this bed perfectly made Hotel standards
that was a cup on the way to the
glorious B wait a minute was that a but
stammer I heard ain't nobody gonna get
me through these double extra security
locks no way in hell now under the
walk-in closet that houses all of my
ghosts
oh ho those ghosts are a little saucy
today better lock them tight oh you're
not getting out of there ghosts haha now
under the laundry room ooh
spacious enough for 14 people at once
this is where I hide my bodies goochie
goochie goo and now on to the bachelors
favorite device microwave filled to the
brim with nothing because markiplier
doesn't need to eat
yay now on to the rest of the home
look at this kitchen counter sink Villa
look at this step okay look at my team
and that is all for the tour I hope you
enjoyed this but there might be just a
little more around the corner it's that
handsome man again oh boy oh boy it was
just an elaborate ruse to trick you now
on to the second bathroom and shower
equipped with a camera that you can see
markiplier is beautiful face every time
you shower don't worry he can't see back
[Music]
it's my favorite mustache I always wear
this when I'm going on hot saucy prom
dates wait a minute
is that another butt stabber entrance I
smell gotcha oh it was just another
closet but every closet is another way
that you can get stabbed in the butt so
buyer beware hello me hello Tim what a
wonderful day
always close your doors or else though
grandma of death is going to come to
your home and ruin your day
also she'll bake you cookies so that was
pretty much the entire tour but wait
it's time to say goodbye in the second
bathroom always leave the pelvic
thrusting to professionals and if it's
too much for you remember to reverse
gyrate for everyone's safety thanks for
watching